so as a social experiment I try some of
the techniques from your book at my last
job and it worked out great to follow
suit how can I Tim Ferriss my love life
and and and yes I just used your name as
a verb I'm sorry how can you temper your
love like what was the second part and
yes use your name is as a verb oh okay
and that means I can't trademark my name
if that catches on turn into the Kleenex
of love life automation how can you
embarrass your own love life well for
those of you who are not aware I'll
share a very brief story so when the
book was about to launch there are a few
things I did I planned a number of
stunts of sorts and I also withheld a
number of blog posts for two years all
right so there was a post called geek to
freak how I gained 34 pounds of muscle
and 30 days or something like that which
went everywhere and one of the one of
the critiques was wealthy this happened
two years ago what took you so long
so well what was the benefit of me what
was the benefit to me of throwing it up
two years ago now I have a book launch
makes perfect sense now I'm on wired so
that's why but one of the other things I
did is all psych yeah how can I get into
at least a local paper I had no
resources related to medium PR guys none
like I was very very guerilla in the
beginning stages so it's like how can I
get into the San Jose Mercury News of
the San Francisco Chronicle
so then sites like FARC could
potentially pick something up and
probably the highest traffic site that
most people perhaps not heard of here
really really great site how can they
get on FARC or whatever dig that was
another reason I did that keep the free
thing and I figured out that if I if I
took the outsourcing and just outsource
my my love life for a period of time
that could be interesting so what I did
was I was living in San Jose nicknamed
man Jose for good reasons and at the
time and what I did is I went to Elance
and I posted a project which was setting
dates for me
coffee dates in an online calendar and
recruited half a dozen teams from around
the world India Philippines his team of
Americans in Jamaica working for like $4
an hour said that was very unusual I
Ukrainians but have you and they all had
the spec sheet they had and they it was
very professionally done and I had this
is tremendously offensive to some people
please try to have a sense of humor and
then I had links to like I this girl I
find attractive this girl no not so much
and it was it was very specific like
these are good interests like you know
tattoos and heroin not really my thing
maybe and really made a detail as if I
was that you know sending out up a
project for you know request for a
proposal and signed up all these these
teams and they competed so there were
performance bonuses and there was for
the number of gates they could set for
me initially it was going to be all over
the map like I'm available on Thursday
from this date to this day this time to
this time Monday from this time to this
time I was like man that's gonna be a
nightmare for 20 minute coffee dates
that's gonna be a disaster
really interruptive so it's like well
why don't I try to batch my dates like I
batch my email so I had all of the dates
set for one weekend and not only that
but I was like how far can i push this
obviously I'm not recommending that
everybody do this but like how hard can
I really push the stuff like okay well
let's say I'm particularly uninspired to
put forth lotta effort let me have all
the dates all the coffee dates at three
coffee shops on my downtown street which
was five minutes walking this was like
20 20 20 20 20 20 20 20 20 and they they
ended up they ended up booking more than
20 coffee dates in two days
and it was confusing it was really
confusing and then oh boy I mean there
was some there were some glitches there
were some bugs one of the so for example
I gave them a discretionary budget of
something like $50 each to
- beak beak report I said be creative
this is terrible wording it's like be
creative if there's another site or
profile that I'm not currently using
because I delegated a profile to each
person or each team rather so it's like
all right match goes to this team this
goes to this team Yahoo Personals let's
say and then plenty of fish whatever and
then some teams would get to because I
was like all right you have to take the
weighted average like matches a huge
advantage so I'll give them two or three
profiles and I give them this
discretionary budget and they had rules
of things they couldn't do but the
Filipino team really ignored this and
what I found funny was first I said
there they were Canadian and they're
using French names and stuff they're
like sorry we got to you a little late
the bridge in Manila was down I was like
what warning sign number one and then
warning sign number two was they forgot
to put a date in the calendar and this
poor girl if she shows up and I had my
head my headset on there's nothing
scheduled I was just listening music and
she's like hey - man she started like
throwing out all these inside jokes and
I was like aha
yeah and the team had been impersonating
me they hadn't been there their
instructions were very clear they were
supposed to be like dear Beth you know
Beth this is like venkatesh you know
neuro cool writing on behalf of mr.
Timothy Ferriss or whatever so like part
of the litmus test was like do these
girls have a sense of here where it's
like you have to - when you get
something like that but what they what
they had done is have these elaborate
they've done all this research I mean
done these elaborate like I am
conversations and all these inside jokes
and she's like you're forgotten all
about our you know conversation about
this I'm like oh that was the only real
glitch but ended up ended up with a at
the time a long-term girlfriend out of
it and that is something I had not been
able to do as depressing as it is to
admit and like six months of going out
to bars and clubs and parties and so
forth so can it work yeah if you wanted
to to embarrass your look but caveat
emptor watch watch the French Filipinos
but
that would be that would be one approach